Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today, I am extremely excited I feel like every time I start out a video
I'm really excited because usually I'm unboxing something cool, and I get to show you guys something amazing and today
That is no exception. We are unboxing the new
Mavic platinum this actually has a few new integrated features that are different from the original Mavic you can fly up to 30 minutes with
the new intelligent flight battery
And it has 40% less noise so if you thought the original Mavic Pro was quiet
Then this thing is definitely way more quiet than the previous and soon
We'll find out so some of you who may be new here may not know
But the Mavic pearl has a very special place in my heart and just think guys don't get it confused
This is the Mavic pearl platinum the original one launched last year, and I got a chance to go to, New York
We got the drone early we created a really fun video to be a part of the whole keynote event and it was so much
Fun and I had the best time I got to go in the stage
I got to talk about how drones have really changed my life
Specifically with the Mavic because it's so small its compact the quality is incredible so basically you can take this thing anywhere
It's great because when I was on stage
I actually had my purse with me, and I was like I've got a drone in my purse
Which usually would be a joke, but now it's a reality
Especially with the spark now. I'm getting off on a tangent either way this is
The new drone that we're gonna be unboxing today the mavet Pro platinum they also announced a Mavic Pro Alpine. It's beautiful
It is all white and it is absolutely fantastic look
It's unboxing gonna be heading up to Big Bear so I will give you guys a nice flight demo as soon as I get there
But right now. I gotta unbox and get on the road
Period is is a more platinum color which is awesome hence the name platinum hello, baby
here's our controller pretty much the same as the previous Mavic and the
Platinum avek right here my gosh this thing is awesome. If you guys haven't seen it already
I also did a really fun video on the DJI goggles
Which these are also compatible with so if you guys are a huge fan of flying with the goggles?
And if you've never experienced it it is definitely something that I feel like if you don't go and buy them yourself find a friend
Rent them and try flying in fpv because it is just it's it really does feel like you're flying
But you're on the ground and it really is so confusing to your mind because you're like what is
Happening right now in the latest math a firmware update
It will allow you to do fixed-wing mode
So if you're flying fpv this will give you a much better experience when you're flying with the goggles
There's also the new Kwik shop function so if you guys are familiar with a spark
This was really great because you could do a bunch of really cool quick shops
And it'll say it directly to your phone. You can save it share it and it's pretty awesome
Let's see what else we've got in here. We have got
cut a power cable
micro USB
This is what you connect your phone
This this looks pretty much identical to the previous Mavic so if you do have an older maverick
You can also use that charger. Yes, they've got an extra set of propellers, which are also very important
It is always nice to keep these handy
Just in case you break a blade because if you do you can just pop these on and you're ready to go
But I like that these have a new silver tip on them
I need to get myself to an Apple store and check out the Alpine version because I bet it looks so fresh
Take a look at this new battery like I said, this is the new intelligent
wolf-like battery
much like the phantom pro 4 if you're familiar with that they also have a different line of batteries that will allow you to
Fly a little bit longer
I'll tell you what when you're on the air those extra couple of minutes are very very crucial you excited to see it
It's not like I haven't seen it right here. Yes. Yes. Yes, I didn't think the bottom was gonna look this good
I'm actually very surprised
I thought that it was gonna be like a lighter gray color
But I didn't realise that it was gonna be so shiny just like the other
Previous Mavic these little guys have fold out is fold well as well when you put this in sport mode
Let me tell you what it is fast
It looks really really great. I'm so excited. I'm gonna go grab my other maverick. So I can give you guys a side-by-side comparison
Here's our platinum and here is our, mammoth Pro
Now these are both pro models
But this one definitely has some higher specs like I said is the 40%
Quieter you get the longer flight time I get to fly with my new iPhone
Which speaking of which look at this nice look you guys look great together. This is clearly gonna work out very very well
What is this do you want? The gold tips they have two different colors?
This is crazy silver comes on them in the gold are the extra ones that's kind of cool well
I'm gonna go charge
This up set it up
And then I'm heading off to Big Bear and I will do a flying demo and I'm looking forward to seeing what you guys think
There it is that's the Matic pro sounds like
While we
Now we're gonna climatic Pro platinum
We've got it right here, so let's see what this sounds like in comparison to the pro
Just up in the air. All right you ready done
I'm really sure I can tell a difference. I mean is it 30% 40% 50%
I'm not sure a percentage, but I think it sounds quieter sounds like butter have you ever listened to a stick of butter?
Pro platinum this thing is so amazing I still have a sticker. I don't even take off because it was brand new